congratulations this week is huge for
you your debut single boys is out how
are you feeling
i feel
i feel like i'm on a rollercoaster of
emotions right now but i am so excited
because i've literally put my heart and
soul into all of this the song the video
so i just hope everyone loves it as much
as i do jesse we got oily jelly [ __ ]
acting real messy still a bad [ __ ]
whether i'm sporty or i'm dressy i don't
know why i got the dudes that can zesty
but i only want a bad boy
nicki minaj is on this track which is
huge by the way how did that happen how
was it to work with her did you even get
to be in the studio at the same time as
her
so she obviously i've worked with her
before when i was in the group little
mix um so i kind of already had like a
bit of a relationship with her already
um and then when i wrote this song boys
like there literally was no one else i
wanted on the song other than her like i
knew that she was just perfect for it
like she's to me she's the queen of crap
yeah so i
like wanted her on it and then
like we labeled buddies as well which
helped so our label made it work she
heard her she loved it and then wanted
to jump on it and and then we like shot
the video i think about it's been about
two two and a half three weeks now i
shot with her and it was just so much
fun oh yeah we loved working bro and i
respect her so much as an artist
[Music]
there's so much to take in
okay
looks
there's so much going on it's one of
them videos where you're going to watch
it and then you're going to want to
watch it again because there's so much
to take in
which i love and i just hope that people
get that real nostalgic feeling when
they watch it
are you guys going to break the internet
i feel like you are
i'm putting it out there they are going
to love it i've been listening to it um
and it's so catchy it's so fun
why was this the song that you thought
was the best song to make your debut
single
well lots of reasons i
was going for a breakup when i wrote
this song um
and
i
feel like it's a topic that a lot of
girls can relate to yeah
i've
you know i can't help but love a bad boy
and i don't know why i think a lot of
girls do and i really wanted to write a
song about that so i just knew there's
so many girls that could relate to it
and also
the fact that i've got to sample the
diddy song which is a song that i grew
up on as a kid if you don't feel me that
means you can't touch me it's ugly trust
me get it right dog we ain't never left
we just move in silence and rep to the
death like 90s 2000s rb music is hip-hop
is like my
ear on my genre of music that i feel so
passionate about
[Music]
i want to talk about your love for bad
boys for a second
what what is it about bad boys
that you're just so drawn to
i don't know honestly i wish someone
could help me
anyone that genuinely
just like on the outside looks like a
little [ __ ]
i love it like honestly i'm so drawn to
anyone that just looks a bit naughty
that's why i say like i do genuinely
love i love tattoos i love boys with
gold teeth i think i i had it
and
i can yeah the first time i ever say i
don't think i'd ever want it again after
experiencing the heartbreak that i did
it was like horrendous and i would much
rather go back now to someone who
treated me like a princess and like who
was actually a really nice guy but i
think what i need to do is find the best
of both worlds so find someone that on
the outside looks like a bad boy but
actually on the inside it's just a
really lovely person
and those exist let me tell you there's
good guys out there that have a little
bit of edge and that's
that's the key right absolutely i think
john is for me it's not it's necessary
that i want a bad boy and someone that
treats me bad because like i would never
want to be an advocate because i was
like yeah i love someone to treat
tonight
i think just finding the balance of like
finding someone that challenges me and
and someone that like keeps me on my
toes a little bit like i need that
especially with like the industry that
i'm in and i like i feel like in a
relationship i'm quite a
i feel like quite a dominant person in
the relationship
in any way like i feel like quite i
don't know i feel like a lot of men get
intimidated by me anyway so when i'm in
a relationship i kind of genuinely feel
like the man in the relationship so like
i need to i need to find like my equal
yeah i love that and you will find it
are you single now i am single as a
pringle and i honestly
can say that i'm not actually looking
for a man right now because
you got to focus on you and
yeah i've got new chapters
on i haven't got time for boy drama
[Music]
i will say and you brought this up you
are part of little mix for so long how
does it feel to put out music as a solo
artist
um compared to releasing music as a
group
it just feels liberating because for the
first time ever i'm like getting to
speak my truth it's so hard to to do
that when you're in a group because to
like get across
all your stories between four girls in
one song it's so hard like you can't
really do that so you kind of just have
to run with the concept and go with it
with us now like i've got so many
stories to tell and
like i'm a very honest person there's
not a lot of stuff that my fans don't
know about me and so it's really
important for me to like write music
that my fans can relate to
i just feel like yeah if they listen to
it and it helps like two people i feel
like i've done my job like i want to be
that artist where people listen to my
music and they're like god she really
helped me through this time in my life
i love that are you working on the new
album then can we expect it this year
you can't expect it this year because
i'm actually still working on it um okay
you can definitely expect an album
definitely next year for sure next year
what what are you writing about right
now what's you know triggering those
heart strings everything so a lot of the
songs we wrote about my heartbreak were
about
just stuff that i was going through
mentally like as a person my struggles
my insecurities the things that there's
just there's so many different songs on
there that i think a lot of people will
be able to relate to and there's like a
lot of ones that really like mean a lot
to me like so close to my heart
and then there's some real sassy clap
back songs yes it's like it's just a
true representation of me as an artist
and i just i'm just can't wait for
everyone to hear it i'm so excited i am
i like that you brought out that you
want to write about your insecurities
because i do think a lot of girls
struggle with that i know you've been
very open about the hardships that you
went through in your 20s you said it was
a really painful time
you turned 30 earlier this year
um it's a big deal what what are you
looking most forward to i guess this
next decade this next
chapter um and how have you learned from
your 20s i guess
oh gosh i mean the thing is like i've
obviously learned a lot but there's
honestly like nothing i would change
because it wouldn't have made me the
person that i am today and i honestly
don't think i'd be as strong as i am i
haven't gone through all of that but i
think my 30s are all just just about
being positive and good energy and
having good positive people around me
that want to lift me up and build me up
and who are on that same team with me
want to support me
and just putting out music good music
that makes people feel good and
that people can relate to i can't wait
to get back to performing like i feel
like i haven't performed in such a long
time so that is i'm in rehearsals next
week actually to rehearse for something
that's really exciting so yeah i just i
just can't wait to just get on my new
journey now just positive vibes and good
fun feel good music
how how is your mental health i mean
we've been in this pandemic for a long
time you did leave the band in december
how how are you
honestly like this is the happiest i've
ever been
i just feel really like content with
myself for the first time ever like i
don't wake up anymore with anxiety and
like don't get me wrong i still have my
down days like and i think that's just
us
human beings and
that's normal but i think the fact that
i don't wake up and and panic and have
anxiety enough and not having like panic
attacks anymore like is a true sign that
i'm really like getting better and yeah
i just i just feel so much love and
support by my fans and my team and the
people that i've got around me and i
just feel in a really good place
that makes my heart happy to hear oh
thank you so much that's so sweet
since the history of time we've seen
people in groups decide to leave and
become the most massive
successes
ever i mean camila cabello
beyonce
zane malik
did you get advice from anyone or did
you talk to anyone about your journey or
is there anyone's um i guess career that
you're like oh i like how they made this
move and that you felt inspired by i
wouldn't necessarily say that anyone's
inspired me like i was doing it for me
because of how i was genuinely feeling
like i just knew that i couldn't
continue
like carrying on with feeling the way
that i was feeling because it wasn't
healthy and it also wasn't nice for like
the other girls to be around so
i had to do that for me but um yeah in
terms of chatting to like other members
of other bands
like liam payne has reached out to me
he like was just like you know if you
ever want to talk niall did as well he
was really sweet he sent me a lovely
message
so nice those boys are so nice
so lovely they're so sweet um and then i
know that uh camila like commented about
my documentary and i think she said like
i'll get it like i totally understand
what she was going through but yeah i
haven't really actually spoken to like
any um any girls personally
but um it would be interesting to like
see if they like had any similar
experiences to me
i think it would be interesting and i
was saying earlier i feel like what the
industry does and
the hardships already that come with
being a woman in this industry and then
to put a bunch together and to sort of
create this air of like competition and
to make people feel bad i just think
i hope that that doesn't happen to to
more people moving forward because i
think there's like an issue there
massively definitely especially when
you're in a group as well like the
comparisons
is just a lot to deal with and i think
that's that's what drives a lot of
groups to break up because
there's always like one that's supposed
to be the like the main one and the one
that should be singing the most or the
one who's the prettiest or the most
handsome and it's like
gods just all be equal just all like
like you've all got the same dream
you've all gone in this for the same
reason but you know what that's one
thing i
can say that i loved about being in
little mix is we all stood for the same
thing like none of us wanted to be the
main one we all like had the same
passion the same vision and i love that
that was one thing i loved about being
in little mix like and i think that's
why we lasted such a long time you guys
did really you guys had so many hits too
and i think girls could tell that there
was something special about
about you guys
are they aware that your new song is
coming out no i actually haven't spoken
to them for a little while now but yeah
i don't know i know that they're like
all doing their thing now they're all
like obviously taking especially perry
landed taking breaks they've had their
babies which is amazing yeah but i
actually haven't i haven't spoken to
them but yeah
i love them all to pieces so no bad
blood it's just good to kind of take a
little mental breather absolutely i
think it's important it's a big change
that's happened in all of our lives i
think it's just time to like like you
know go our separate ways and take a
breather and just take a step back and
focus on like
generally like what's all going to make
us happy and i think we're all doing
that at the moment um i know that you
said an album is in the works and that
you think next year anyone that you
would love to get on that album now i'm
like could we expect nail or liam
never know no there's so many people i'd
love to collaborate with like i love
dojika so much yeah excuse me that would
be epic i love really irish
i love
it honestly i love bruno mars i love
daniel caesar there's too many people
like my list goes on and on but yeah i
are definitely there's definitely going
to be more collaborations
well if anyone can make it happen i know
it's you you did mention that you have
rehearsal next week are you gonna go on
tour what's going on
well i mean
as of yet there i mean there definitely
will be a tour but i'm not rehearsing
for that josh chair okay okay
this is just for like um
the performance of boys which is really
exciting okay where are you performing
can you say i can't say yes okay all
right all right fair um and then i guess
before i let you go what is the biggest
thing that you want people to learn
about you as a solo artist that maybe we
did not get to see from you in little
mix
um
just that i'm like being i'm now being
able to be like my 100 true authentic
self like i don't really feel like i was
when i was in the band i was i feel like
i was trying to be someone that
i just so badly wanted to be accepted by
other people and i feel like now i'm
just like i'm so content with just being
me and doing my thing and doing the
music that i love and i just really hope
that people see that in my music because
like i said i've put my heart and soul
into this album and like really like
been vulnerable and honest in my songs
and i yeah i just i just really hope
that people see that when they and hear
that when they listen to my music
you